nous avons fait de notre mieux et ça n'a
rien donné
on gagnera jamais contre robotique à un
contre un mais on est trois contraintes
avec ta force ton intelligence et ma
vitesse on va y arriver ensemble on
gagnera alors nous allons faire front
ici sur ce champ de bataille
[Musique]
ça y est
c'est aujourd'hui le voilà notre moment
que le combat commence
[Musique]
aucun plan
tu aurais une idée il faut trouver son
point faible je dirais
le plus faible arrête de dire entre gens
je sais ce que c'est son point faible
c'est moi c'est moi l'entrejambe
[Musique]
réfléchissez je suis un chemin de cap
dans sa tête si j'y vais que je l'énerve
ainsi se concentrera sur toi ce qui
laissera son foyer à mes attaques et à
celle du journal
hérisson tu es un homme les courageux
derrière qui fait face à une mort
certaine avec honneur il va falloir
travailler tes encouragements ouais
allez on y va
[Musique]
tu me veux viens me chercher je
t'attends tu n'as pas à me dire de venir
te chercher tu peux être sûr que je vais
me dire te chercher je viens te chercher
je viens te chercher je viens te
chercher je viens te chercher
vraiment lourd toi c'est parce que je ne
suis qu'un muscle un million de pour
cent plus vite renard
commencer et avancer allez allez on
court on court on bouge allez non non
non non mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
ici
tu sais à quoi je pense on va sauver
notre ado on prend le volant
[Musique]
je viens de chercher
alors c'est quoi ton projet
je vais réduire toute l'humanité en
esclavage pour qu'elle serve mes
machines d'abord crédits puis l'univers
puis le multivers puis qui sait ça
suffira peut-être attention
tu ne seras pas là pour voir ça
t'es sérieux
[Musique]
crotte de nez
quoi tu abandonnes déjà c'est dur de se
battre contre un adversaire qui fait 700
fois sa taille
tu ne peux pas me vaincre je suis
puissant je suis savoir
je suis physicien
tu ne peux pas jouer au plus fin avec
toi
[Musique]
désolé c'est comme ça épicé tout
c'est fini pour toi Eggman
alors tu as un nouveau look j'adore bon
et si on laissait le passé n'être qu'un
mauvais souvenir j'ai eu mes torts toi
aussi il y a des gens bien dans les deux
camps
entre personnes intelligentes
on devrait pouvoir s'arranger
[Musique]
c'est comme ça d'accord
ok on est pas amis
oh
le
hérisson détient le pouvoir de
l'émeraude je suis désolé mais il n'est
plus le Sonic que vous avez connu quoi
[Musique]
il faut absolument que tu
d'accord c'est bien le Sonic que vous
avez connu
[Musique]
c'est tellement bon de retrouver sa
couleur bleue être un Super Sonic en or
c'est rigolo mais je préfère le bleu
perso
dis-donc toi on t'a jamais dit que tu
devrais apprendre à gérer ta colère tu
me rabais avec tes petites moqueries
mais tu ne sais rien de moi
hérisson en tout cas ce que je sais
c'est que les équidés adorent débarquer
sans prévenir et me gâcher la vie te
gâcher la vie encore une moquerie
gratuite à cause de toi sache que j'ai
tout perdu tout ma tribu était au seuil
de la plus grande de ces victoires la
dernière des chouette avait été
localisée les secrets de l'émeraude de
l'enclos étaient sur le point d'être
nôtre mais mon père m'a empêché de me
joindre au combat le moment viendrait où
je pourrais honorer ma tribu mais ce
moment n'était pas venu ce furent les
derniers mots qu'il m'adressa et je ne
l'ai jamais revu
toi et moi on a tout perdu ce jour-là
au revoir
[Musique]
non non c'était pas un piège
prends
[Musique]
la boutique
je t'en prie tu as il se réveille toi il
aide son ami renard au lieu de
reconquérir la boussole bien entendu
nouvel ami mais toujours cette faiblesse
pathétique